besoin d'excusé jo sont pour l'épisode 3
de inside c'est parti on était donc en
haut de cette échelle on va descendre
braconner sur la chaleur je vais
corriger ce que j'avais 10 pas du tout
une entreprise autoritaire c'est
carrément la société c'est le monde qui
est comme ça ça se résume pas à trois
bâtiments c'est tout le pays qui est
dans cet état
et du coup c'est toujours pas pourquoi
ni les intentions qu'il ya derrière
voilà les gens sont totalement son beef
y est quoi mais on peut les contrôler
avec des casques
alors où l'assassin semble un bureau
d'un pdg et un sous marin mais qu il
faut que je me cache faut que je me
cache faut que je me cache qui se fait
là c'est bon ils voient pas lâché nos
membres à temps ça met la pression on va
lui voler son sous marin
non hop on passe quand vous allez me
voir ce sera trop tard
je peux sauter dedans mais will you do
you l'omonia aller au nom mais pour de
vrai les mecs
bino c'est génial c'est d'une beauté
c'est de toute beauté j'étais après
avoir du poisson au bifff yella contrôlé
à base de casques mon sens [ __ ]
s'enfonce de ou fin mais je me demande
sur le port ces chalets est-ce que je
peux attraper quelque chose avec ça non
je peux pas
ah si si si il y avait un trou hockey
enfin j'ai rattrapé mais une porte s'est
ouverte
ça c'est un mur ça oui c'est un bon gros
mur mais là on peut redescendre c'est
faux nathan mais à bien une sortie dans
cette salle la hâte un mec déjà et elle
n'est pas très réglementée d'armes ya
toujours un panneau de secours issue de
sortie bien lumineux c'est quoi ça aux
enchères est pas eu cette fonctionnalité
à j'ai compris les à mi parcours ne sont
pas très bien compris les développeurs
le la notice des contrôles on doit tous
de vie des bouffes voit la hausse est
beau navet là par contre va y avoir du
poisson geremek sa part totalement
subvertie cas qui m'ont cité
c'est hyper beau j'ai vraiment envie de
fermer ma gueule regardez-la faut y
aller il ya une brèche
on l'a vu c'est une beauté
alors on continue d'avancer dans cette
ambiance posée tamisez une porte porte
numéro 2 terminal 2 ok pour montréal
blocs 1
voilà c'est une merde c'est s'est
stabilisé du coup vraiment bon c'est un
peu glauque
une faille merde mon [ __ ] j'suis
vraiment une immense merde amis à une
grille derrière en fait ça alors il ya
une grille d à la grille n'est pas qu'à
ça que je suppose un mail le mur il ya
des fils de fer deux ans et incassable
voilà j'ai vraiment tout péter
rien n'y fait est-ce qu'on peut pas
juste sortir du sous marin
pas moyen ah bah voilà hélas en
hivernage ans c'est pas ça mais oui
voilà [ __ ] c'est correct
du coup y avoir un bouton pour l'ouvrir
l'autre côté je suppose mais 14 c'est
terrifiant c'est sûr ça qui a forcément
un monstre sous marins je n'irai pas
jusqu'à dire monstre du loch ness mais
pas loin
ok on nier on n'en parle plus dégagez
les rats on va tirer sur elle ça ouvrait
la porte là bas ça c'est ça c'est quoi
ça vous monte allez on y va
voilà
[ __ ] avec cet espace immense il ya une
lettre qui s'allument on est foutu voilà
le gros bouton qui va nous permettre
d'ouvrir la porte d'en bas c'est sûr oui
oui je suis pas et je suis basé j'ai pas
ouvrir la trappe avons arrêté ok cette
fois on va connaître ta vie tu vois pas
se faire avoir deux fois mon gars je
préfère te le dire
des primes aux eaux
oh mon dieu encore de la pression
gratuite j'en ai marre du coup on est
d'accord ça a dû ouvrir la porte qui est
tout à gauche ce gros bouton rouge qui
devait mettre des boutons de porte aussi
loin [ __ ] c'est comme si pour sortir
de ta résidence le bouton se trouvait à
dans la rue d'à côté métaphore à chier
alors est-ce que j'ai raison est ce que
ça a bien ouvert la porte
oui non d'accord fallait retourner là où
les rouleaux sont apparus est passé de
l'autre côté et donc le bouton la portée
encore buffet chaud en fait assaut j'ai
juste plus besoin du sous marin en fait
je suis en train de me dire mais je
l'aimais bien [ __ ] ça m'embête dessus
c'est que ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est quoi ça all hallows part 2 1 déjà
bizarre au hockey on va démarrer
qu'est ce que ça a fait ça va exploser
ou attend c'est fantastique ça un
skateboard du futur je pense que je
saute au bon moment vas-y envole toi y
est nickel à dente on se dirige vers
sous main la gt1 soumaré ya je suis
désolé je vais pas vous mentir corde si
je la rate
ok [ __ ] quand je roule au [ __ ] tu
recommences bien tous tu feras voilà où
était le bouton à
là c'est bien le bouton de la porte on
la voit en bas ni qu'elle allait plus
qu'à plonger
hop on va aux sous marins on le fait
sauter et on est bon oh c'était quoi ça
oh mon dieu
votre vie ils sont voilà maintenant on a
peur d'aller dans l'eau [ __ ] allez on
y va nickel ça ça passe nickel
il fera rien sous marin terminant sous
marin de nous arriver là ok en bas y
avait donc une planche en bois à payer
voilà parfait tout en finesse un comme
ça la créature nous a pas entendus du
tout elle viendra pas nous manger
fallait que je sorte et que j'appuie là
dessus c'est ça j'ai compris allez on
s'y colle
l faut faire vite parce que c'est quand
même vachement profond pour un petit
garçon de 5 ans allez allez allez nickel
on y retourne vite avant de mourir c'est
bon ça ou vers quoi exactement à saab
est le niveau de l'eau hockey atome là
faut faire un saut de ouf mais qu on n'a
pas les capacités 1 à bosser bosser même
championne du monde deux sont en sous
marin ils le passent pas celui-là parce
qu'on tient du coup j'ai pas bien
compris à quoi servait le bouton
s'ajuste à baisser le niveau de l'eau
mais pour quoi faire se servent à rien
en fait on avait besoin de plus tôt pour
passer le souk et là bas c'est un piège
up et là on passe du coup
il va falloir y retourner à la nage et
ça va être un timing hyper serré way
[ __ ] mais dans tous les cas on pourra
plus le passé attention en appui ok on
va mettre le sous-marin pts et la porte
on va y aller à la nage un et on va
revenir à la nage normand pourra passer
entre les barreaux vu qu'on est tout
petit il ya juste le risque du monstre
qui est à prendre en considération va
pas se mentir
hop on y va hop nickel monde est nickel
on s'est mis très très bien
j'arrive dans les minutes pièce s'est
passé [ __ ] soirée géniale
allez on avance bon bah je préfère
franchement je préfère l'eau que les
mecs sont contrôlés par les casques
c'est glauque au hockey ça va le rebelle
qu'est ce que tu fais là
arrête arrête les vielles choqué un show
qu'elle a bien changé leurs robes elles
jettent est une idée faut peut-être tout
le temps à les laisser dans la lumière
elle n'avance pas tu vois le recul la
voilà ce fait moins la maligne à a été
achevée au petit prix pour the grudge tu
vas te détendre tout de suite ça images
se dégage s'ils font sens ok on est
passé ce qui nous suit encore à la
fabrique à l'unité je peux vous dire
qu'elle n'a pas rater les cours de
pissila au collage et merdias murs non
la lumière au génie qu'est la game
non non faut que j'aille en bas je fais
de la merde
arlette j'en ai marre à faut que je
passe travers ça vous pensez à temps ça
se casse çà çà la sas cas c'est sûr
allez on prie non si c'est ça c'est ça
il faut mettre plusieurs coups c'est
super compliqué avec ça dégage faut
fermer ça hop là elle pourra plus jamais
venir nous péter les couilles
saloperie de grade alors avoir pété ce
truc tranquillement maintenant que the
grudge genou poursuit plus il va aller
sucer une autre à moi je vous le dit
voilà c'est parfait est ce que l on veut
sortir de cette mère totalement teba
voilà je crois que mon rêve s'exaucer
une demi seconde
hop là ça dégage tu as tu es chaud alors
allez on ouvre on a l'habitude
il a fait régresser de ouf sept enfants
oh merde merde merde merde merde merde
je crois que j'aurais dû sauter des fois
il faut vider fois il survit pas génial
dans tous les cas je veux ouvrir ce si
ça va nous servir avant que ce soit une
grange derrière astrologie tout [ __ ]
c'est loin un oui dans le désert la
mecque c'est un truc de ouf la perse
personne alors sa puce et on est solo à
voile à regarder triple bouton monga
[ __ ] faire quoi il faut être deux se
trouvent compliqué on va continuer
d'avancer
voilà voilà lui chez google nous aider
lui où il va nous tuer c'est pourquoi 19
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça salut 18 19
info m 19 sec sur la table mais mec
c'est abusé mais vous m'avez pris pour
qui est génial je pense qu'il va avoir
18 mec dans la cellule tout au fond là
bas du coup voilà lé christ et et sur ce
truc donc quoi pour faire quelque chose
à quoi ça sert
ok d'accord on monte ok on est en haut
il ya deux côtés on va voir à gauche en
premier une cage mais c'est pareil elle
va être rôle à fond je la pousse non
mais je pouvais pousser sa mecque c'est
impossible c'est impossible il faut il
faudrait qu'on soit plusieurs pour
pouvoir faire ça je vais l'autre côté
puis on va voir sous ce mot si ce
n'était pas les tâches du dessous en
fait il fallait aller à la mort certaine
ouais on peut pas atteindre l'autre côté
allez on descend au sous-sol alors à
gauche on n'a pas forcément y avoir un
casque c'est obligé hier des layènes
corde il va falloir qu'on la teigne je
pense pour monter comment faire
peut-être un objet à pousser voilà on va
tirer sa non mes mecs c'est beaucoup
trop lourd
c'est beaucoup trop lourd prions pour
qu'ils aient un petit casque ou un truc
qui va nous aider à voilà ça sent bon ça
ça sent très très bon hockey au à merde
on est piégé
bon c'est pas grave une échelle pourra
pas remonter non plus ah voilà les amis
bonjour comment ça va les gars là il y
en a déjà cinq faut juste attendre le
casque en haut et on est bon on ne
pourra l'atteindre par par un endroit
c'est sur elle et on traverse avant de
mourir noyé dans la fosse où france ok
on est bon tafforeau traversé un mur
hockey et j'espère qu'on aura pas une
drogue on a peur du zoo graja ok c'est
bon [ __ ] film est finalement en fait
on s'éloigne beaucoup trop de la plaque
stop au civil va servir à rien en fait
ok
non habana on revient vers labadens et
je pense que c'est vraiment nous juste
que c'est super long on y va c'était
limite me suis bien chez dessus oh oui
c'est beau c'est de toute beauté
la planche qui cela se passe te plaît
c'est bon du coup on va atteindre le
casque les gars [ __ ] on va prendre les
cinq mecs quoi pouvoir pousser le
chariot vis du droit ça va être cette
incroyable c'est incroyable le casque
est à nous mais non mais non un casque
portatif
c'est une meilleure invention que le
téléphone portable le casque un portable
mecque et vous pouvoir me soulever mais
non mais ceci est génial et ya soulevé
moi ouais ouais ouais merci les mecs ça
fait tout juste assez génial ben voilà
c'est génial on est on est en train de
faire une armée d'hommes son visage le
contrôleur mentale allait ramener vous
les gars venez venez les cache pas vous
avez des bisses elle se passe là en
avoir besoin
on va tirer un train les gars allez
venez tôt mais du coup je suis
instoppable même s'il fit couler les
gardes du parc où il arrive on est
pépère on va amener tout ce beau monde
là on avait besoin de ça pour sauver les
ports tirer des trucs et vont nous aider
de ouf
alors ici qu'est ce qu'on avait j'ai
tout là bas à gauche y avait une grille
s'était très loin mais bon y avait une
grille jeu max payne the grudge adam
dunn a ramassé bombardant c'est beau
allez on soulève les gars ouais au bas à
plusieurs ça parce qu'ils aiment voilà
du coup il y avait quoi là dedans plus
de hockey un de plus nickel on continue
faudra aller en face il ya un levier
vous pensez que vous pouvez me faire la
courte les mecs là ça marche pas ça
marche pas ça marche pas et ben retour
là bas
ok on notera de métal ici je crois qu'il
ya une cage avec des mecs de dents au
pouvoir l'a poussé j'espère que ma
grand'mère pas voilà ça fera toujours
trois de plus je trouve très bien sait
très bien ce truc correct
aya venait désolé ça dégage
attends je fais pas mort à allah vous
allez pouvoir m'en voyez non les mecs
vers là-bas envoyez-moi vers la bas oh
oui c'est beau ouh là là il ya un mec
morlaàs à l'eau tu vas te lever me
servir mon pote un faux je tire ses
clouque faut que je tiens vert ouvert là
bas on pensait faire tomber sur la
plaque
je pense à ouais c'est bien ça allait
bien avec nous on va tomber à plat
ok les gars j'en ai un ça dégage au
mercy [ __ ] vous êtes tellement adoré
son adorable et est tombé là normalement
elle et péter non ils sont morts non non
c'est bon tout va bien plus tard nous a
fait peur les gars vous croyez morts
allez venez l'armée voilà de plus trois
de plus lui il va venir il nous en
manque sept dont les trois là bas
récupérer avant de la retirer ça allait
on tire ça venait les amis à mon avis
truc c'est de là le mettre sous le trou
là haut comme ça on pourra tomber tu es
eu le pousseront pendant ce temps là eh
ouais attention et ce que j'ai fait le
bon move oui c'est magnifique
il me pousse tout seul je n'ai rien à
faire merci beaucoup alors je trouve
tout à l'heure je vais chercher cette
audience a bien qu'ils aient ça c'est
fait est-ce qu'on va pas retomber sur le
chariot detroit mais canon pardon lourd
en ont assez bon scandale au clame un
petit ascenseur émotionnel
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça de
l'électricité on va on va d c'est une
trappe à cinq moteurs j'adore à avatar
7e boma encore c'est ça nul nul à chier
à jenny dégénéra faire mieux mais on va
le bloquer en dessous avec sa up
oh là là là là qu'on est mal un [ __ ]
elle a du coup on a logiquement la
hauteur pour atteindre ce truc oui trois
mecs en plus salut les gars en plus je
vous mets bien je vous fais tomber petit
confort il ya du sable en dessous à lons
casse ont rejoint les autres relais mec
allez on y va on concède pas mal là
alors attendez faut régler cette
histoire de train là à temps ok j'ai
compris à mon avis il faut le faire
remonter d un moment à désolé les gars
oh oui oh où il a botté c'était
incroyable ils sont quatre c'est bon
pour ouvrir la plaque [ __ ] je suis
tous ensemble tous ensemble tous ok qui
at il sous la plaque c'est le moment de
vérité avec la piste musique et tout est
bonne et tout donner tout sauver tous ok
astuces pour ouvrir cette porte
ok les gars c'est parti on va découvrir
et à des bruits de tirs et d'explosions
mais qui en plus est le suivent pas non
vous me suivez les gars très bien j'ai
passé de quoi j'ai aujourd'hui pour
passer au niveau suivant
ok bah voilà j'en suis à prendre c'est
le 3e épisode sur inside n'y était pas
allé mais ça vous a plu
la 5 ans à partir ancien qu'on entend
comme des bruits d'explosion et hou donc
peut-être qu'en fait c'est la guerre
dans une certaine zone et que dans
l'autre zone bas les gens vont déjà été
son beef y est je ne sais pas peut-être
j'aime et des théories tout claquer on
ferra leur projet l'épisode à la 13e
prochaine vidéo merci à vous regarder
portez-vous bientôt en bis